provided
it isn't conceived only as an exchange
of mutual favors
or is uncalculated way in advance as a
profitable investment
love release a unique trust placed in
chance it takes us into key areas of the
experience of
what is different and essentially leads
to the idea that
you can experience the world from the
perspective of difference
love is a quest for truth truth in
relation to something
quite precise what kind of world does
one see
when one experiences it from the point
of view of two
and not one what is the world like when
it is experienced developed and lived
from the point of view of difference and
not identity
we shouldn't underestimate the power
love possesses to
slice diagonally through the most
powerful oppositions and
radical separations the encounter
between two differences
is an event is contingent and
disconcerting
on the basis of this event love can
start and flourish
it is the first absolutely essential
point
the surprise unleashes a process that is
basically
an experience of getting to know the
world love isn't simply about two people
meeting and their inward looking
relationship
it is a construction a life that is
being made
no longer from the perspective of one
but from the perspective of two
love cannot be reduced to the first
encounter because it is a construction
the enigma in thinking about love is the
duration of time
necessary for it to flourish in fact it
isn't the ecstasy of those beginnings
that is remarkable
the latter are clearly ecstatic but love
is above all
a construction that lasts we could say
that love
is a tenacious adventure the adventurous
side is necessary but
equally so is the need for tenacity to
give up at the first hurdle
the first serious disagreement the first
quarrel
is only to distort love real love is one
that triumphs
lastingly sometimes painfully over the
hurdles erected by time
space and the world to make a
declaration of love is to move on from
the event encounter to
embark on a construction of truth the
chance nature of the encounter morphs
into the assumption of a beginning
and often what starts there lasts so
long
is so charged with novelty and
experience of the world
that in retrospect it doesn't seem at
all random and contingent
as it appeared initially but almost a
necessity
that is how chance is curbed the
absolute contingency of the encounter
with someone i didn't know
finally takes on the appearance of
destiny
the declaration of love marks the
transition from chance to destiny
and that's why it is so perilous and so
burdened with a kind of
horrifying stage fright love is an
existential project
to construct a world from a de-centered
point of view
other than that of my mere impulse to
survive or
reaffirm my own identity to love
is to struggle beyond solitude with
everything in the world
that can animate existence love
is maybe the hardest thing in the world
[Music]
restaurant
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
hey guys so the narration was an
abridged excerpt
from the book in praise of love by the
great french philosopher alain badu
i discovered about you a few years ago
when i was introduced you to his seminal
work
being an event which is an extraordinary
philosophical work
as you probably realized while watching
the video but you is a very romantic
guy he considers love to be the most
profound human experience
but also the most difficult one and i
totally agree with him
love is the ultimate provocation to our
ego in order to love you need to forget
everything you know and operate in a
space where
individuality morphs into togetherness
but you also state something very
important in the book in order to love
you need to learn to love
love is the rebirth of the self through
the prism of difference
love cannot be reduced to the first
encounter because love is a construction
that's something very crucial to ponder
because in our current day and age we
tend to favor superficial relationships
over deep connections
we reduce our interpretation of the
other person to a social media profile
and to simplistic interactions
we don't know how to behave what
questions to ask and how to transcend
the ordinary
we exchange partners and we swipe
through people like they're something
completely disposable
that's how we lose our humanity that's
how we lose the
romantic aspect of our relationships
that's how we lower the quality of the
collective consciousness of our
societies
i hope this short video helped your
attention to shift away from this
madness and remind you what true love is
all about
as i thank you for making it to the end
of the video i would like to give away i
learned about used book
in praise of love to one of you all you
need to do is like
subscribe get notifications and comment
below
the winner will be decided by a raffle
in a week from now
and i will broadcast the raffle through
my instagram account so make sure to
follow me there too
i will reply to the winner through the
comments down below so stay tuned
again thanks for watching see you soon
adrian out